why is it that only pigs can sniff out
truffles these things stink like
every time they're out in a restaurant
why is it so hard for anything just
smell these things there's a sex hormone
found in the Truffle that the male Pig
lik why I like it yeah they're
aphrodesiac is that what it is truffle
an AF you I'm always horny so it makes
sense that I love truffles the outside
of it kind of looks like a cow nose that
needs to be hydrated I think that's it
for me I don't think I'll ever read
truffle ever again truffles remind me a
lot of this phenomenon in in Hollywood
boutiques if they're having trouble
selling an item instead of putting it on
sale they'll make the price higher to
trick people into buying it to me that
is truffles truffle Sal when I put it on
it does make it kind of taste like
a sweaty sock in a way that I
like I don't know where what's else to
tell you